right so
first things first i mean
congratulations um
it must be the weirdest possible time
for you yeah i know yeah the you know
the range of emotions going through your
head right now so um but let's just go
back to brass tacks um tell me how this
even came about okay so um
it all started on tuesday i was working
away it got to about four o'clock and i
thought i'd probably better buy a ticket
because i saw the jackpot and you buy a
ticket regularly i do i normally buy
them when you know this it's a good
amount so when there's a lot of money i
i'll put it on i use the app and i have
a quick check you know a couple of times
a week and then i'll i'll put it on but
generally my um luck is pretty terrible
too
i've been sticking with it for years but
never more than a small amount or a
lucky dip it's a big win for me
so yeah they tried to convince me to buy
them thinking i'll have more luck but
yeah
so yeah i did that didn't actually it's
funny because normally i'm more aware of
it but i didn't actually think any more
than that was really busy trying to get
everything done for work
um called it a day went you know carried
on with a normal life went to bed and
then at 5 15 the dog normally go feed
the dogs and do some jobs around the
house went back to bed and half half an
hour and just checked my emails my other
bits and pieces
and um the weather is a normal one for
me and then
so i i
checked my emails and i had an email
saying that i'd won a prize and i you
know took it as the usual lucky dip type
thing and i opened up the app logged in
and then i looked at the amount
and i put the phone down
and i picked the phone up again and i i
looked at the amount again
uh and i thought it's you know i first
thought it was in thousands and i i
thought were you excited that it was
thousands yeah i was i was over the moon
thought you thought you were 148 pounds
yeah and i i was really
life-changing you know we can you know
with the mortgage and everything else
that you know
it was going to change our lives and
i actually started counting the digits
and at that point i thought
yeah yeah
yeah it was uh yeah
amazing but also unsurreal it didn't
feel cool so i put the phone down and
jess hadn't had a great night's sleep so
i thought do i wake her up don't i wake
her up what do i do so i just sat there
for a minute
trying to take it all in and i thought
well i'll give her because it's only 20
minutes i'll give her an extra 20
minutes till her alarm goes off
and i um started because normally in
life
we've been trying to move house for
quite a while and other bits and pieces
we've not been a huge amount of time in
the house we're in now so
you go on the right move and you set
your limits on what you you can't afford
and in the past everything we've kind of
wanted is far beyond what we could
afford so i thought i don't need to
filter i can actually
look at anything i sat there away to
myself thinking oh this is ridiculous
yeah and i still didn't really believe
it but it was fun you know it was like
um yeah so let's make believe at that
point yeah it was yeah and then so then
you wake jess up some water by the way
yeah he let me wait until my alarm went
off and then normal husband and wife
grumpy morning i was like just let me
turn the alarm off first give me more
ten minutes more yeah and he was like i
got a secret to tell you i've got a
secret to tell you yeah
and then he told me i was like don't be
stupid because that's the natural
reaction right yeah he's like no
i really think we have i was like oh joe
let me have a look at it thinking you
know it's the morning he just
didn't have my glasses on he's got it
wrong yeah yeah and then i was trying to
do it on my phone but i couldn't get it
to work or something i was like yeah and
then i we just kind of thought this is a
fun game to play like it's obviously
wrong there's something wrong with the
app
hey let's go with it and let's enjoy
this moment of thinking we've won the
lottery because it's not real and yeah
we said
we'll call them at eight o'clock when it
comes on and check it out
and then i was like right i'll go make
coffee yeah and get on with the day kind
of thing yeah you just thought you know
there's some there's an anomaly here you
might have won something but let's just
get on with the date normally and i
thought it was all right news app tells
everybody they've won the euro millions
that's what i thought would be yeah yeah
yeah but yeah it wasn't so yeah and then
at that point um eight o'clock we
thought we were dead a phone and see and
then it couldn't we couldn't make it up
i had a really terrible phone signal
we're walking all over the house the
lady at the other end is speaking to me
i kept rip i had to keep repeating all
the information going through like
security checks and i'm thinking this
this this you know and then and
eventually it waits one of those needs
15 different times in different ways and
yeah yeah and uh
we ended up in one of our kids room next
to the window like trying to get signal
and then
all of a sudden the lady was so sweet
wasn't she she was amazing quiet on me
and said i'm going to put you on hold
and then
come back to us and confirmed it i still
didn't believe it at that point she was
so sweet she said joe was like i think i
think we've won the lottery and she was
like oh okay telling us all the stuff
how much do you think you want and he
was like no i think we won
and um so then went from there so then
she was like and then she said put us on
a hold and she came back on and she went
you definitely have one
jim was really sweet and excited yeah so
when that when you put the phone down
from that do you then
what happens then you have a moment to
yourselves i mean obviously it's still
sinking in now yeah it was i didn't
really think it was real did i yeah no i
don't know i just we just thought yeah
yeah well
we didn't yeah i was i was reasonably
we they told us somebody would ring up
we were expecting ratify it all and
everything yeah so i was i was on there
we were waiting for that weren't we yeah
it was definitely it was seeming more
real but still not that joe we were just
checking back uh uh uh in a room and you
showed me that the
the app yeah your app and you've still
got the balance of nine pounds eighty
which i love and then underneath you've
got you've won and then just only that
you click in when you've won you get all
kinds of money that comes up and it's
assumption it's it's quite hard to
quantify that yeah yes yeah it is and
then so yeah we
thought we'll wait for the next phone
call and i just
we just went off with the girls to
school and i logged onto my laptop and
started work yeah and i went to work i
was on my way to work and i said to joe
i rang him and i said because i work
with my mum and my sister and i was like
i we're just not the family that could
lie to one another just you know we're
really close family and i couldn't have
gone to work and not told them something
so i rang joe and i was like joe i'm
gonna have to tell my mum something i
can't lie to her and he was like it's
fine just please don't tell her how much
or get her excited or just ted don't
tell anyone just say we want to say no
we know this is yeah
yeah so then
i called her and said oh are you on your
way into work mum and she's like yes and
i said i'll meet you in the car park and
she said to me afterwards she was like
you're so weird you never weep me really
it's quite a strange thing to say to
your mom isn't it yeah
so then
i met her in the car park
and i was like i said i've got something
to tell you a secret to telling you but
you have to promise not to tell anybody
she was like okay she said and then she
was like are you pregnant i was like no
i said actually what i said was it's
better than being pregnant
so so um
i said i think we've won the lottery
and she was like
the euro millions
and i was like
well joe said i i shouldn't talk about
it i don't want to get you she said have
you won the euromillions and she knew
all about it exactly how much it was
down to the paper down to the team
and i was like i couldn't hold anything
i was like i don't know we're waiting
for a call but i think she just
literally screamed in the car park and
burst into tears because
even though it's wonderful and exciting
it's also a massive relief for everybody
that's been struggling with all their
bills and all their things for all this
time like we're like every normal family
that
have that thing so it's just a huge
relief okay so let's go into that so
tell us a little bit about yourselves uh
what you do for a living and and your
life
so okay so i work for communications
company and basically obviously like
most people from lockdown i just sat at
home log on 8 30 or 8 in the morning and
sit there 12 6 6 7 6 30 at night and
just chug away at the keyboard so
my life is generally that during the
week and then
weekends aren't it pretty much will
revolves around diy and and just trying
to kids and our kids trying to get stuff
done because the house we live in needs
loads of work today and that was
basically what we were doing every
weekend i was just saying
like jess we need a bigger fridge
because the list of things i've got just
carries on going down and down and down
i can't get it all in in one space it's
that big so yeah it's
it's you know these are the things you
do in life you know to get what you're
trying to where you're trying to get to
but yeah it's been pretty hectic though
so you just get up pretty much just
chase your tail until you go to bed yeah
yeah 5 15 i get up and then that's it
for 11.
we constantly discuss that we don't
watch telly because we just go until we
stop well yeah you get the kids to bed
yeah we're just normal yeah so i um
have a hair salon with my sister and my
mum
so i run the business side of that
and um
i
have we have a kids so my kids go to
school like the primary school and then
i work four days a week and
we have too many animals yeah too many
hands-on that we look after so yeah
we've got geckos
yeah yeah we've got two geckos yeah we
have horses ponies
and dogs and yeah i mean it's it's yeah
it's good too many things exactly you've
got you've got these things yeah you're
working to pay off these things and yeah
you know and you want your kids to go
around yeah we just want to create that
kind of lifestyle for our children we're
right at the bottom because we've you
know pushed everything to
to get this house that we can have our
ponies at home
and um that's been our dream we thought
we'd hit the biggest dream
we have so much work to do i was telling
them before like we have a bucket in our
hallway that collects the rain every
time it rains you know you you're
working hard and you've got you
the stage in your life where you've you
know you've got your children
and but you're working hand-to-mouth to
yeah we
we've
we've got we've saved to do some
building to the house but that's what we
have and we're waiting until it's not as
expensive as it is right now
yeah things but yeah we're not
i'm not saying that um
it's horrendous no we you know we love
our life yeah this is what we've chosen
we absolutely love it yeah absolutely
and that's why we're where we are i
think when when i met you in a room next
door um guys the first thing that uh
that thankfully uh came to me was this
you both got this incredible amount of
humility about yourselves and you were
aware that the world is we're in a very
tough place at the moment living crisis
inflation going up
those things you know
you're aware of those things and and and
how lucky this is yeah i mean
you know that the way of the world is is
crazy and it's reflected our lives and
this this couldn't i mean
you couldn't it's not just us though
before
electricity to heat the water you know
all the people you know
people aren't coming through the door
because
those normal things do you worry about
going public
i i have been really worried about going
public yeah just because
i want to protect the people i love
i want to make sure that they're all
okay
and
yeah it isn't really something that i
i've dreamed of doing absolutely but i
feel this is the way that we can be
honest to them all we can enjoy it with
them all and it's going to allow us to
give them loads to them
thank you thank you
hi both there naftas jared from the bbc
um just wanted to ask on that subject of
on that subject of going public are you
worried about scammers people coming
forward who might want to take your
money from you is that one of the
concerns around going publicly i haven't
even i haven't even thought of anything
like that to be honest we're a week in
we're like so overwhelmed by other stuff
i i just haven't even got to consider
that if i'm honest we're trying to think
of all the positives that i mean that's
the main thing of this is there's a lot
of positives so yeah
next
thanks hi bradley harris 5 news uh do
you both feel that you have a
responsibility now with the sheer amount
of money that you've won given that
we're in the middle of a cost of living
crisis
um i don't
it's
this is also new to us that there's a
lot of things we've got after this we've
got to go away we've been so busy this
week just trying to you know with work
and everything else just trying to get
everyone else in a good place that
because obviously we knew we
we're gonna but you know i think those
people are in the same boat as us so
absolutely we
we um get where they are but we just got
to get our head around this
yeah and think things through and move
on from there i think
hello there matt drake good morning
britain
two questions first of all we're using
the same numbers and if so was there any
significance to those numbers and more
importantly
who's going to play you in the film
[Laughter]
so um i always go with the lucky dip
because i just think that's easier it
just i just buy a lucky dip on either
the lottery or the national lottery
depending on which one looks like it you
know it's got a lot there's a lot of
money there and yeah that's it my um my
family my dad played the lottery all of
our when we were growing up and he
played the same numbers every single
week um he died about seven years ago
and kind of joe took on the baton as the
one who did the lottery for our family
so he started off using those numbers
but he'd forget them or get them wrong
or something so we then went to lucky
dip so that it was luck but yeah it's
unbelievable because that's what my dad
dreamed of all his life and tried used
to say to us frequently imagine if you
won the lottery think about if you win
the lottery and um
yeah it's just crazy
but who's going to play you in the film
i mean yeah
it's another you know
that's another one
things that crossed my mind there's a
whole list of things that
you've got some stanley tucci vibes
going on
[Laughter]
congratulations first of all ben chapman
from itv news you've talked a lot about
spending time with family
but is there one thing you've always
dreamed of buying
um we're not really those materialistic
people you saw our house you would know
that i you know but i don't i think
i'll probably buy a new car i'm sure or
something like that but we haven't got a
huge yeah we'd love to go on a family
holiday
more experiences yeah we have we'd love
to we had to go buy suitcases to come
here because we don't go on holiday we
never go on holiday um so our kids would
just
die to go to the sun and do that kind of
thing so i'd love to go and do that yeah
that's the main thing that they've
talked about is holidays yeah
so uh yeah so my our youngest constantly
has always wanted to go to hawaii i
think youtube's to blame for that we
have no idea why but they're obsessed
with the world the other one wants to go
to like a texas ranch the trail thing
where you can ride courses across there
so you just said that yeah yeah they
know
i think we'll work from there
thank you
joe and jess steve nibs from the bbc as
well um huge congratulations first of
all from the local bbc you've talked
about helping family and friends that's
almost a no-brainer this is such a huge
amount of money are there any causes
close to your heart that you're going to
try and do something philanthropic with
the money help charities or causes that
that you work that you've got no i think
that's an area we will get to but we're
one week in
it's blown our mind just getting to this
point and um you know we're we're not
there yet but we're going to definitely
take some advice and talk to people
about this go from there because yeah
it's yeah
it's just is this the first moment it's
real yeah
yeah this is very real yeah so up until
this point i still keep thinking i'm
gonna like fall out of bed and and it's
all gonna be yeah a dream my mum my man
yeah exactly right yeah
my mom keeps texting me saying are we
alive i'm like well we're all not alive
if we're not alive so it's okay
we're together in that situation your
mom's deep